[Music]
well I think the American Dream is safe
to say if if not dead it's on life
support you know it's this idea that if
you do well you can get ahead in life
and if you have family and kids they can
perhaps do a little bit better than you
did and what we know by the numbers is
that the median wages in this country
haven't budged meaningfully in nearly
forty years and yet the cost of living
has increased by some counts by up to
thirty percent so there's a sense that
people are working hard but only a small
group of people or getting extremely
lucky while everybody else is really
staying in place and you know I think
that we have the power to change that
that's the key idea that I talked a lot
about in the book is that we've created
an economy that is structured this way
we made specific decisions around how to
encourage automation globalization and
the rise of Finance that have created a
small group of very lucky people and we
have the power to change it to make sure
that economic prosperity is much more
broadly shared so I know when it comes
to the position that we're in now I
don't think it was one single moment or
one single event that got us here I
think instead it was the collection of a
lot of different decisions that began to
be made in the late 1970s in early 1980s
and we've continued to make in fact all
the way up through for instance the end
of last year the tax code is one of the
most important things we've consistently
lowered tax rates on corporations and
the 1% while not giving a break to the
people who need it the most at the same
time we've ushered in an era of
globalization which by all accounts has
created economic growth but without
fundamental worker protections to make
sure that people who are in industries
that have moved overseas have been
protected and we've also made positive
decisions obviously like investing in
the internet for instance which was a
government investment initially which is
created the opportunity for companies
like Facebook and Google and many others
to rise precipitously but the all the
fruits of that innovation and of all the
the
positive things that come with that
growth have not been evenly distributed
a small group of people are doing
extremely well and at the same time as
everybody else is trying to make ends
meet and just as we had the power to
create the economy in this current
configuration I do believe we have the
power to change it there's been debate
for decades about whether trickle-down
economics is it's the way to go and we
could talk a lot about economic theory
but in some ways I don't think we really
have to we can just use a little bit of
common sense if you put a hundred
dollars in the pockets of someone who's
working hard to make ends meet
they're gonna spend a lot of that money
most of that money on things like child
care housing health care wherever their
bills are the highest you give someone
who's in the 1% an extra hundred bucks
that might spend one or two but the vast
majority of that money is going to get
parked in a bank account and not really
become part of the productive economy so
one study by the Roosevelt Institute
showed that if you provided five hundred
dollars to every American every month it
would increase gross domestic product by
about seven points over the next eight
years so this idea is not just about
making sure that that the wealthy pay
their share it's also about creating a
kind of broad-based prosperity that's
good for all Americans the the poor
middle class and wealthy alike so my
belief is that sometimes the best
solution is the simplest we should use
cash cold hard money to empower people
to chase their own dreams and to
re-energize the American dream
specifically we should provide five
hundred dollars to every person who
works in America making less than fifty
thousand dollars to enable them to spend
it on what they choose housing
healthcare education gas to go interview
for a job it's these kinds of decisions
that I believe fundamentally the people
who are working hard are the best
empowered to make and we can use
something called the Earned Income Tax
which has been massively popular for
decades on the left and on the right to
do this with a meaningful expansion and
modernization of it we could combat
income inequality with a in a way that
would make a historic dent in poverty
and stabilize the lives of tens of
millions of people in the middle class
as well I think those people who've done
the best from this new economy do have a
responsibility
they got a chance to climb the economic
ladder many of them also got lucky
fortune 500 CEOs are some of the
hardest-working people out there they
also get very lucky and there's a
responsibility not to pull the ladder up
behind them so in my view we should
raise rates on income in excess of two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to
the historic average of 50% and also
close some of the most egregious
loopholes in the tax code like the
Buffett Rule which enables Warren
Buffett to pay a lower tax rate than his
assistant and if we do those things we
can pay for a guaranteed income of $500
a month
in the here-and-now today I mean the
rough cost anybody who says that this
idea is too big the rough cost of this
over the decade would be just a bit more
than the total costs of the Trump tax
bill that was passed just a few months
ago so this is imminently affordable if
we can develop the political will to
organize for it
[Music]
you